[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka a friendly
neighborhood spider-man and after the
world premiere of far from home last
night we finally have official word on
what happens in the film's post-credit
scenes of the last week I've been
putting together all of the rumors but
now that the film is slowly being
released we are finally seeing what it
entails throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the final scenes of the
film and discussing how they set up
future movies there will be full
spoilers here so if you don't want to
know anything about the film then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for click in this video I
hope you enjoy it now sit back relax and
let's get into my breakdown of the
post-credits scene from spider-man bar
from home ok so the first scene picks up
with Peter Parker swinging through New
York with MJ Peter successfully defeated
Mysterio in the movie and it seems like
all this works out for the webhead
he drops MJ off and lands on a lamppost
which is when he sees on a large Madison
Square Garden screen that there is a
news report from the Daily Bugle net
they've apparently acquired an exclusive
clip and the show is hosted by none
other than Jay jonah Jameson have played
by JK Simmons he plays a video that
Mysterio made in the film which appears
to show that spider-man has been the one
behind the elementals and that he
stopped Mysterio so he could replace
Ironman as the world's number one hero
Jameson calls him a menace and brands
him as a liar that killed the world's
greatest superhero before he shows the
second half of the video which reveals
that Peter Parker is spider-man it's big
news Peter Parker is devastated and we
cut to black similar to the ending of
homecoming in which Aunt May discovered
that Peter was Spidey so what does this
mean well similar to the Civil War
storyline the entire world now knows
that
Parker is spider-man but there's a lot
more weight added to this as they also
think that he murdered Mysterio wilds
Marvel are no stranger to showing the
identity of their heroes this will of
course cause problems for the
wall-crawler who is still in high school
going forward I think Peter will have to
either fake it so that this isn't the
case however with the Bulger already
knowing this things could become
difficult it definitely gets me amped up
for the rest of the MCU and I can sort
of see the villains joining together to
make a sinister six for the third film
the second scene starts off with Nick
Fury and Maria Hill transforming into
Scrolls which are none other than Talos
and his wife from Captain Marvel this
was leaked heavily online last week and
it turns out it's true which adjusting
is crazy a lot of people are kind of
nagging on this scene but it means that
I'm far from home the two shield agents
have in fact been Scrolls the entire
time and this explains why fury gets so
angry about Peter dissing Captain Marvel
early in the movie it turns out that
Nick Fury and Maria hill are in fact on
vacation to you and whilst they
initially seem to be on a beach they're
actually on a scroll ship going forward
this means that Scrolls are still around
and have been slowly getting involved
with world politics which definitely
teases a return for them in future
movies if we get some kind of Secret
Invasion stuff that'll be amazing but I
guess we'll see what happens going
forward obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on these spoilers and what you
think will happen in the film's for the
future comment below and let me know and
if you enjoy this video then please like
it and if you'd like to see more
spoilers then make sure you check out
the rumored leaks from the premiere
which will be linked at the end it
covers all of the movies part and it's
definitely worth checking out so I'll
leave it linked after this this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for take the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]